mire el vídeo completo antes de inyectar
la insulina
es posible que su proveedor de atención
médica le recomienda usar una jeringa
para la inyección de insulina a fin de
ayudarle a controlar su nivel de azúcar
en sangre la inyección de insulina con
una jeringa implica seleccionar un área
de inyección preparar la jeringa y la
insulina y luego inyectar la insulina en
el cuerpo su proveedor de atención
médica le indicará qué tipo de insulina
necesita así como también cuando
necesita inyectarse y qué cantidad
necesitará toallas humedecidas en
alcohol el frasco de insulina una
jeringa nueva para cada inyección y un
recipiente para desechar objetos
punzocortantes para tirar las jeringas
usadas
una jeringa desechable tiene las
siguientes piezas un cilindro
un émbolo
una etapa de la aguja y una aguja
cómo seleccionar el área de inyección
antes de inyectar la insulina seleccione
el área de inyección en el cuerpo las
áreas para la inyección de insulina
incluyen el abdomen o el vientre los
muslos la parte posterior de los brazos
y las nalgas
cuando seleccione el área de inyección
asegúrese de usar un área diferente cada
vez que realice la inyección colóquese
al menos dos centímetros y medio de la
última área de inyección inyecte la
insulina al menos a cinco centímetros de
su ombligo y seleccione un área que esté
a dos centímetros y medio o más de
cualquier cicatriz o lunar cómo preparar
la jeringa y la insulina
paso 1 lávese las manos con agua y jabón
y luego seque se las paso 2 si es
necesario mezclar la insulina haga rodar
suavemente la botella entre sus manos no
sacuda la botella ya que podrían
formarse burbujas en la insulina antes
de inyectar se revise la insulina en la
botella para asegurarse de lo siguiente
que sea el tipo de insulina que le
prescribió su médico no más allá de la
fecha de vencimiento no decolorado y que
la insulina no tenga grumos paso 3
retire la tapa del frasco de insulina
usa una toalla humedecida en alcohol
para limpiar el tope de goma en la parte
superior de la botella paso 4 retire la
jeringa del empaque asegúrese de usar
una jeringa nueva cada vez que se
inyecta insulina paso 5 retire la tapa
de la aguja de la jeringa
no toques la aguja ni permita que entre
en contacto con ninguna superficie y no
use las jeringas y la aguja está doblada
algunas jeringas tienen una etapa en el
émbolo que también deberá quitar paso 6
jale hacia atrás el émbolo para absorber
la cantidad de aire igual a la dosis de
insulina
paso 7 sostenga firmemente el frasco de
insulina sobre una superficie plana
presione la aguja a través de la goma en
la parte superior de la botella presione
el émbolo para inyectar el aire en la
botella de insulina deje la aguja en el
frasco esto ayuda a mantener la cantidad
adecuada de presión en la botella y hace
que sea más fácil extraer la insulina
hacia la jeringa paso 8 con la aguja aún
en el frasco coloque el frasco y la
jeringa boca abajo paso 9 jale el émbolo
para llenar la jeringa con sólo un poco
más de insulina que la dosis que
necesita si ve burbujas de aire golpee
el cilindro de la jeringa con el dedo
para que suban a la parte superior
presione lentamente el émbolo lo
suficiente como para eliminar el aire y
la insulina adicional paso 10 revise con
cuidado para asegurarse de que la
cantidad de insulina en la jeringa
coincida con su dosis de insulina quite
la aguja del frasco y coloque con
cuidado la jeringa en una superficie
plana y limpia
asegúrese de que la aguja no toque nada
como inyectar la insulina paso 1 limpie
el área de inyección con una toalla
humedecida en alcohol realice un
movimiento circular para limpiar el área
de aproximadamente 5 centímetros de
ancho
paso 2 aprieta un doblez de 5
centímetros de piel en el área de
inyección limpia paso 3 sostenga la
jeringa como una pluma e introduzca
rápidamente la aguja directamente en la
piel en un ángulo de 90 grados asegúrese
de que entre la aguja entera en la piel
paso 4 presione completamente el émbolo
hasta el tope para inyectar la insulina
en el tejido adiposo debajo de la piel
cuente lentamente hasta 5 antes de
retirar la aguja para asegurarse de que
se haya inyectado toda la insulina
paso 5 quite la aguja de forma recta
para extraerla paso 6 deseche la jeringa
en el recipiente para desechar objetos
punzocortantes nunca deseche las
jeringas ni las agujas directamente en
la basura comuníquese con su proveedor
de atención médica si tiene preguntas
sobre la inyección de insulina o si su
nivel de azúcar en sangre permanece por
encima o por debajo del rango objetivo